sergey yashin kopf wurde gefoltert
geschlagen und gedemütigt sergej ist
journalistin russland und die die ihn
gefoltert haben waren polizisten sein
vergehen er hatte von einer anti kriegs
demonstration berichtet nachts holten
ihn die polizisten aus seiner wohnung
verprügelten und misshandelten ihn
stundenlang
ich hatte schwere kopfverletzung davon
sind einige narben am kopf
zurückgeblieben eine schwere wunde hatte
ich genau da
sogar meine arme waren ausgelegt das war
vor mehr als einem monat fast zwei
monate ist das jetzt
wir sind unterwegs nach borowski 100
kilometer südwestlich von moskau wir
begleiten sergej zu seinem ersten dreh
seit seiner verhaftung
er will einen künstler porträtieren der
sich gegen den krieg einsetzt er geht
ein hohes risiko ein denn die behörden
haben ihn auf dem schirm
das ist gefährlich
denn wir leben in russland und da sind
journalisten immerhin gefragt
ob es heute gefährlich ist nun ich kann
damit umgehen
sergej porträtiert heute wladimir of
jeannie kopf der künstler ist in der
ganzen stadt bekannt seit beginn des
krieges hat er zahlreiche wände mit
friedens symbolen gemalt allein dafür
kann man hier dieser tage probleme
bekommen wer für den frieden ist ist
gegen die armee und damit gegen russland
anwohner haben berichtet hat sich fertig
waren noch am selben tag für die
buchstaben z und v aufgetaucht sind
und v sind zeichen für den krieg
wladimir hat die buchstaben direkt
wieder übermalt es sind kleine
widerstände gegen eine große übermacht
noch läuft der dreh ruhig niemand greift
ein doch das kann sich jederzeit ändern
sagt sergej uns er hat vor dem krieg
hauptsächlich für den unabhängigen
sender dort gearbeitet doch den gibt es
seit anfang märz nicht mehr die meisten
seiner kollegen haben das land
mittlerweile verlassen der 35-jährige
aber will mit seiner frau und seiner
tochter hier bleiben obwohl die geleast
in russland sind journalisten in größter
gefahr viele geraten zur zeit ins
fadenkreuz der behörden dieses
polizeivideo von vor drei wochen zeigt
die festnahme des chefredakteurs einer
lokalzeitung
immer wieder werden bei demonstrationen
auch journalisten ab geführt obwohl sie
deutlich als presse gekennzeichnet sind
die medien in russland sind seit beginn
des krieges komplett gleichgeschaltet
und unter staatlicher kontrolle
die propaganda des kreml ist
allgegenwärtig und heizt die stimmung im
land an selbst ein atomschlag gegen den
westen ist kein tabu mehr
es geht um die deutungshoheit in diesem
krieg es geht um das narrativ wer sind
die guten und wer die bösen videos
zeigen heldenhafte russische soldaten im
kampfeinsatz und bei humanitärer hilfe
angeblich wird sogar eine ausgabe von
mein kampf gefunden die botschaft ist
klar russland kämpft in der ukraine
einen gerechten kampf gegen nazis
seit kriegsbeginn ist das budget des
verteidigungsministeriums um elf prozent
gestiegen und das der staatlichen
informationsstellen also vor allem last
des staatlichen fernsehens hat sich
verdreifacht
und beim militär nur um 11% für den
kreml ist propaganda das wichtigste
sie katharina kottrup katze und t shirt
co wollen dieser propaganda etwas
entgegensetzen die beiden deutschen
journalisten sind aus russland in die
georgische hauptstadt tiflis geflohen so
groß die angst vor staatlicher
repression im studio steigt die
anspannung es sind nur noch wenige
minuten bis zum start der sendung die
beiden machen das was sie in russland
nicht mehr tun können sie berichten für
ihren youtube kanal unabhängig über
irland
wir werden heute selbstverständlich viel
über die ukraine sprechen und über den
krieg den russland dort führt
krieg allein das wort ist in der
berichterstattung in russland verboten
im exil studio in tiflis arbeiten 17
journalisten fast alle aus russland fast
alle geflohen nach beginn des krieges
auch hier katharina und tischen haben
russland anfang märz verlassen die
journalistische arbeit war zu gefährlich
sie hatten große angst
es war sehr schlimm natürlich
ich finde es keine chance das zuzugeben
es war die hölle ich hatte richtige
panik
mit beginn des krieges in der ukraine
hatte der kreml den letzten unabhängigen
stimmen in russland einen maulkorb
verpasst internetseiten wurden blockiert
sender vom netz genommen
es waren einfach bedingungen unter denen
wir nicht weiterarbeiten konnten
entweder verwandeln wir uns wegen des
neuen mediengesetzes das fake news über
die russische armee unter strafe stellt
in eine außenstelle des
verteidigungsministeriums
oder wir berichten weiterhin über alles
so wie vorher und gehen dafür ins
gefängnis
gefängnis oder freiheit maulkorb oder
journalismus katharina und tischen sind
froh ihren beruf in georgien frei und
ohne einschränkungen ausüben zu können
sie wollen von hier aus weiter
unabhängig berichten und über den krieg
sprechen
sergej will der staatlichen
unterdrückung in russland selbst etwas
entgegensetzen und geschichten wie über
künstler wladimir erzählen die polizei
hat diesmal nicht eingegriffen sergej
will dafür einen youtube kanal starten
obwohl er weiß dass ihn das ins
gefängnis bringen kann doch schweigen
ist für ihn keine option
[Musik]